last week I went to CES in Las Vegas but
I nearly my pants when I saw this AI
powered smart toilet from Coler it's got
heated seats ambient lighting and
emergency flushing capabilities for
power outages during the apocalypse but
something doesn't smell right with its
$88,500 price tag today we'll look at
all the craziest Tech from CES 2024 to
get a glimpse into our Aid driven
dystopian future it is January 15th 2024
and you're watching the code report the
big theme at CES was you guessed it
artificial intelligence and even implied
that traditional coding langu are dead
in the keynote programming language of
the next decade is not going to be the
traditional way that we've been writing
code it's just going to be natural
language what's funny though is that
literally nothing at CSS is actually
built with AI the reality is that
everything's built with C++ Python and
JavaScript coded by humans however AI is
putting many careers on The Chopping
Block like professional bird watchers
are in big trouble thanks to these new
AI powered binoculars that can
automatically identify government spies
AKA Birds but if you think software
engineering is obsolete another career
you might be considering is a tractor
operator unfortunately those jobs belong
to the robots multiple companies like
John Deere are now showcasing driverless
tractors and Hyundai's concept X
excavator in the near future robots like
this will build in police linear smart
cities just like the one that's under
construction in neom Saudi Arabia right
now with minimal manual labor or
supervision from humans but even if you
find yourself doing manual labor in the
future it'll be a lot more productive
thanks to AI powered exoskeletons this
prox exoskeleton from hypershell is an
AI powered suit that can make you run
faster jump higher and kickass harder
it's got a 1 horsepower motor that can
get you running over 12 mph the most
obvious application for such a tool is
for the military and law enforcement
eventually every police officer and
Soldier will be an Unstoppable Cyborg
and that's great for Humanity because we
can finally eradicate crime once and for
all but crime is a small problem
compared to the upcoming climate
catastrophe if we don't do something
algor is predicting the ice caps will be
totally melted by 2013 it's all your
fault but luckily our trusted world
leaders are flying around on their
private jets trying to figure out a
solution tion like did you know Bill
Gates had to buy four different private
jets that's your fault he's trying to
save the world from useless carbon
emitters like you but don't worry a
final solution is coming another huge
theme at CES was electric vehicles
Mercedes dropped a new all electric G
wagon and there are tons of different
cool looking EVS from Brands I've never
even heard of and this is all happening
while demand is slowing for EVS in the
United States which means these cars
will likely get cheaper and cheaper in
the years ahead but EVS aren't even all
that much better for the environment
compared to ice the real problem is that
there's too many humans consuming too
much stuff but most of them are not
willing to get into the sarop Pod yet on
top of that many people have pets like
cats and dogs also useless carbon
emitters luckily Samsung introduced a
new robot called Bali a cute little
robot kind of like Wall-E it's a far
superior cat or dog replacement it's
powered by Ai and has a built-in
projector that can play videos on any
wall or act as a little security bot
that can keep your house safe while
you're away pretty cool but one of the
most hyped up products at CES was the
rabbit R1 it's a handheld AI assistant
that's kind of like if a smartphone and
Alexa had a baby basically it Con
conects to the apps in your phone and
allows you to control them with natural
language as opposed to their actual uis
thanks to their own custom Foundation
model which they call a large action
model some people have called this the
iPhone moment for the AI era essentially
the rabbit R1 makes UI obsolete you can
remove the word front- end development
from the dictionary because with the
rabbit R1 all you have to do is talk
into the device like you're talking to a
human and it can do all those things you
used to do with your fingers on your
apps the rabbit sold all 10,000 of its
units the first day it was released but
personally I think this thing is
overhyped you could Lally just build an
app that does the same thing instead of
carrying a second piece of Hardware
around with you oh wait it looks like
someone already built that app with
flutter overall CES was totally
overwhelming like I didn't even mention
the Y brush that can brush your teeth in
10 seconds or the new Hyundai electric
air taxi or the transparent TVs from
Samsung and LG or the analog keyboard
for your smartphone or how about the
smart lamp that watches you at all times
to keep you safe or come take a load off
with one of these fully immersive VR and
AI powered reciprocating devices CES was
a lot of fun but now it's your turn to
serve your life's purpose and go out and
buy all this useless Crow this has been
the code report thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one